these are the men trying to stop a new
Islamic state caliphate taking a hold in
central Africa the remoteness of this
region makes it fertile ground for
extremism the soldiers suddenly see Boko
Haram fighters in the distance they're
saying they spotted the extremist oh
look there they're running Boko swore
allegiance to is years ago and their
fighters are considered amongst the
deadliest in the world
the terror group is mostly based in
neighboring Nigeria but the border with
Cameroon is open and porous and the Baco
fighters frequently cross over to
terrorize extort money and coerce
youngsters into joining them a farmer
has been shot and his friends
desperately try to haul him to safety
[Music]
his wife with their baby strapped to her
back is distraught
the soldiers frantically tried to give
first aid the farmer has a deep wound to
his abdomen and is struggling to breathe
he's rushed off to a military hospital
all the time here they've been fighting
the scourge of Islamic extremism for
years so far they're not winning but
they can't save the farmer the extent of
his injuries and the scarcity of
resources here mean the odds were well
against him another family's been left
bereft by the terrorism here
[Music]
we're given access to Boko Haram
fighters who've been captured or given
themselves up the Boko fighters admit
they share the same aims and ambitions
of the Islamic state days only they want
a Caliphate here in Africa
we don't want the flag of any other
country I don't want the Cameroon flag
girion flag UN would serve under our own
black to create our own state whole
communities are emptied the border
between Cameroon and Nigeria cuts right
through this town called a shindig with
Boko Haram rampage through hospitals and
schools burning down and destroying
houses the presence of the military has
encouraged some of the villagers to
return there's no room for family here
and the soldiers and says Boko Haram has
been beaten are they winning
[Music]
you're not gonna let them win phenomenal
looking live them but that all seems
wildly optimistic right now and the
international community is given a tough
warning about ignoring what's happening
here at its own peril
Alex Crawford Sky News in Cameroon